[Musik]
ein wunderschöner Morgen erwartet uns in
unserer kleinen süßen skyblock-welt
meine Damen und Herren allerdings dürfen
wir auch heute gar nicht lange Zeit
verlieren denn es steht eine Menge auf
der To-Do-Liste ich fange mal direkt an
mit eventuell einer Frage die euch
gerade aufkommen wird und zwar Luca
warum ist hier gerade Tag und hat
aufgehört zu regnen in der letzten Folge
am Ende war es ja so dass es noch
geregnet hat und es war Nacht ich habe
gewartet ich bin hier stehen geblieben
deswegen sind davor noch keine Monster
mehr da müssen genau da ist ein bisschen
Blut gedroppt allerdings habe ich
einfach gewartet weil mich dieser Regen
so genervt hat und ich keinen Bock hatte
die Folge wieder mit seiner depri
Stimmung zu starten ich schnapp mir mal
kurz hier das verrottete Fleisch und ihr
seht ja auch schon wo ich mich gerade
befinde und ihr seht ja auch schon was
im Titel eingeblendet steht denn heute
geht es um die Monster fahren
denn das hier was ihr gerade
eingeblendet seht wird mir in die
Kommentare geschrieben die sollte
nämlich auf jeden Fall Priorität haben
nicht nur für Knochen und experience etc
sondern vor allem auch für Seide das
werde ich schlafen gehen können ich weiß
dass dort hinten auf der Insel da sehen
wir sogar ist wolle die können wir auch
einfach abbauen und dann haben wir Wolle
für Betten allerdings finde ich das
nicht so schön weil wir dann wieder so
komische Wege in der Luft rum schweben
haben und das wurde mir übrigens
allerdings auch dass hier unten in die
Kommentare geschrieben die Mehrheit war
wirklich dafür lukas ist in Ordnung dass
du cheatest es ist ja gar kein richtiges
cheaten sondern eher was negatives weil
mir diese ganzen Steine dann sogar
flöten gehen aber wir sparen dadurch
einfach eine Menge Zeit also irgendwann
in den nächsten Folgen wenn ich dann
noch cheaten und hier alles mögliche
abbauen und das finde ich diese
komischen Stifte hier immer rumschwirren
haben was mir jedoch auch noch unten in
die Kommentare geschrieben wurde war
dass ich eine Challenge falsch gesehen
habe und zwar hatte ich mir in der
letzten Folge glaube ich was dreimal
grün Farbstoff gemacht und habe mich
groß gefeiert dafür dass ich diese
Challenge geschafft habe die Challenge
besagt allerdings zehnmal grüner
Farbstoff von daher werde ich das leider
nicht mehr schaffen in diesem Projekt
das ist auch Unterschied wertachter
legen werden die habe ich leider nicht
hingekriegt weil ich die komplette
sandsituation die wir hatten von da
vorne ja leider zu Glas verwandelt hatte
weil ich das unbedingt für mein Haus
haben wollte da wurde mir zwar auch das
hier unten in die Kommentare geschrieben
und wegen Luca wenn du da vorne da
irgendwie so eine Plattform baust und
dann ist das ein Sand Biom und dann Spa
irgendwie Wüsten Zombies dann gibt's
eine Möglichkeit aber das ist mir alles
zu kommuniziert weil ich gar keine Lust
drauf dann pack meine Challenge
Antarktis man muss auch nicht alles
schaffen im Leben Gott jetzt haben wir
lange noch gequatscht ihr wisst die Prio
ist heute die Monster Farben und ich
habe mich darauf ein bisschen
vorbereitet ich habe in meiner testwelt
nehme ich mal geschaut wie viel Steine
wieder für wirklich benötigen kann euch
erstmal die anderen Materialien sagen
und zwar benötigen wir insgesamt 64
Falltüren ist machbar kriegen wir auf
jeden Fall hin äh wir benötigen unter
anderem auch noch vier Bruchstein Stufen
davon haben wir deutlich mehr kriegen
also auch hin wir benötigen auch noch
ähm tatsächlich 8 mal Wasser das kriegen
wir auch hin weil wir haben hier von
unseren See wo ich war noch nicht ganz
bin ob wir den lassen oder ob wir den
nicht lassen die Spiegelung hier sieht
ein bisschen weird aus mit diesem
Blättern da vorne sieht aus wie
Schneeflocken schneit es bei euch gerade
bei hier in Köln schneid sie mich gerade
ähm den See weiß nicht ob ich den stehen
lassen werde ob ich ihn abbauen werde
weil es ist ja mit den challenges
generell so wir machen die dann einmal
und dann kann es eigentlich auch wieder
zerstören weil z.B jetzt mit den den
Zäunen oder so die habe ich auch gemacht
dann habe ich die verbaut das heißt ich
habe die nicht mehr weil was haltet ihr
davon soll ich den sie wegmachen oder
soll ich denn hier lassen ich finde
irgendwie ein bisschen störend weil er
so mitten drin ist irgendwie packen soll
und ich mache so einen kleinen See
einfach so unendliche Wasserquelle hier
hinter oder so scheiße in die Kommentare
ähm was wir auch noch benötigen werden
sind 20 Fackeln kriegen wir easy hin äh
20 Fackeln sollten auf jeden Fall
machbar sein mit unserer Holzkohle und
äh was wir halt am allermeisten
benötigen das sieht die vorne auch schon
warum ich mir hier gerade tatsächlich äh
9 Spitzhacken gemacht habe ist nämlich
1200 Bruchsteine
das sind mehr als 19 Stacks
da ich allerdings nicht cheate werden
wir ganz entspannt jetzt erstmal
wahrscheinlich eine halbe Stunde
Bruchstein abbauen viel Spaß bei der
längsten timelaps aller Zeiten
ach so ich trinke übrigens gerade Tee
außer Tasse diesem luca-shop gibt und
was habe ich für ein Wetter an den don't
worry be happy Sweater der gemütliches
Wetter der ganze Weihnachtszeit also
bevor die Tablet losgeht
[Musik]
so meine Damen und Herren es ist endlich
vollbracht ich habe no joke eine Stunde
lang Cobblestone gerade abgebaut das ist
immer so crazy weil es für euch gerade
vielleicht Minute vier oder fünf im
Video ist für mich allerdings schon
minute eine Stunde sieben in der
rohaufnahme ihr seht schon ich habe hier
ein bisschen was gemacht der Händler kam
irgendwie an vor keine Ahnung sieben
Tagen oder so ich habe drei Mal mit
Phantomen gekämpft hier vorne habe ich
jetzt ein Eichenbaum also einfach
gepflanzt weil die irgendwie ein
bisschen Cleaner ist hier vorne hier
vorne allerdings die Fichten wollen wir
weiter wachsen lassen hier habe ich auch
ein bisschen Erde angebaut die ich dort
vorne abgebaut habe habe ich mich die
Bäume abgebaut hier vorne habe ich
Melonen angebaut und ähm habe auch hier
schon mal das ein bisschen angedeutet
weil der Weg hier vorne so weitergehen
soll bis zur Monster fahren da vorne die
Monster da vorne verbrennen ich habe das
alles schon abgebaut und das ich habe
insgesamt glaube ich 21 6 ich brauche
nur 19 allerdings Fall nicht verbauen
sollte dann habe ich das auf jeden Fall
mal so ein bisschen schon mal vorher
provisorischerweise angesetzt dann seht
ihr auch schon mal im Inventar habe ich
fünf Weizen das wollte ich euch
allerdings zeigen bevor ich irgendjemand
sagen würde auf einmal plötzlich ein
Brot ich habe immer zwischendurch so ein
bisschen Weizen abgebaut und dadurch
schlussendlich wo sind denn dieser hier
sind die ähm dadurch schlussendlich
insgesamt fünf Weizen bekommen die ich
mir jetzt auch ich habe Nummer drei okay
das heißt ich kann mir noch ein zweites
Brot machen also dass ich zumindest wenn
ich die Monster fahren baue äh da volles
Leben habe und mich immer vernünftig
regenerieren kann wie ich habe jetzt
auch extra noch mal auf den Tag gewartet
also dass ich die ganze Monster von
meinem Tag bauen kann damit dort nichts
spawnt Creeper und Enderman kann uns
eigentlich egal sein die können noch
theoretisch mal ganz kurz eben in die
Luft fliegen weil wir das da vorne eh
kann ich daran nicht dran weil ich das
da vorne eh alles
neu bauen werde ist vielleicht sogar
ganz gut dass er in die Luft fliegt der
Enderman da jetzt ja keine Ahnung was da
mit dem machen soll ich muss mir ihn
noch mal ganz kurz eine neue Spitzhacke
machen weil ich insgesamt auch einfach
irgendwie 15 oder 16 Spitzhacken als
insgesamt verbraucht habe also ich meine
es ist chillig wenn man sagt man cheatet
nicht und es ist cool zu sagen ich mache
ab alles hier selber gebaut ohne
irgendwie einmal einen Commander
einzugeben
ähm ich habe eh schon ähm vergessen was
ich sagen wollte
wir bauen mal eben ganz auch Knochen oh
chillig können wir Knochenmehl raus Mann
ich brauche mal eben ganz kurz einmal
diese Plattform ist so warm ne
ich habe hier diesen Sweater an aus dem
luca-shop der vielleicht ein Ticken zu
warm ist für meine 30 Grad heiße
dingsbude hier gerade mit den Lichtern
er ist einfach wunderschön also mal ganz
kurz
und ich trinke dazu auch noch einen Tee
und bin hier schon seit anderthalb
Stunden wieder am aufnehmen ich bin ja
echt am Ölen allerdings meine Damen und
die Plattform hier vorne abgebaut ich
ähm werde jetzt mal eben kurz überlegen
wie ich das alles mache es gibt nämlich
sehr viele verschiedene Möglichkeiten
wie man diese Monsterfarm baut die Sache
ist allerdings dass ich mich für eine
ziemlich simple entschieden habe und
zwar brauchen wir dafür erstmal hier
vorne so eine kleine Plattform auf der
wir uns dann halt bewegen können und ich
werde auch jetzt mal eben kurz bzw habe
gerade schon mein crafting table hier
mitnehmen damit wenn ich mir Sachen
craften muss ich nicht mehr nach hinten
muss in das sieht doch tatsächlich mal
ein bisschen Energie also ich habe mir
gerade mal 24 neue bruchsteinstufen
gemacht wir brauchen erstmal eine kleine
Plattform jetzt machen wir eben kurz
noch meine Haare Kiri Aktion werden uns
hier einmal kurz nach unten be so dass
wir hier bruchsteinstufen runter setzen
können die wir jetzt rüber ziehen können
nach hier vorne da brauchen wir
tatsächlich auch noch mal ein paar mehr
zack zack zack zack zack so das sollte
passen und können jetzt hier alles unter
Höhlen so dass wir schlussendlich diesen
diesen Faktor hier vorne das alles
Unterhalt ist noch mal mit Bruchstein
und nicht alles so in der Luft schwimmt
auf den Steinen äh dass du das hier
vorne auch mit rüberziehen denn hier rum
soll dann wieder Sonne auf steinziegeln
folgen das ganze können wir allerdings
später bauen denn hier vorne soll
erstmal die Monster vom stattfinden
dafür bauen wir jetzt einfach mal hier
vorne hier vorne hier vorne und hier die
bruchsteinstufen ab und setzen hier
normale Bruchsteine hin auf denen
nachher die ähm Zombies Creeper Skelette
etc stehen werden und jetzt gehen wir
von hier einige Blöcke hoch auch in
diese Richtung allerdings nur hier vorne
lang denn da drunter kommen jetzt wieder
bruchsteinstufen so dass wir hier noch
so ein kleines Loch haben und uns nichts
etc abschießen können das das ganze habe
ich jetzt einmal komplett drumherum
gebaut an den Seiten habe ich es offen
gelassen weil das ist eh unnötig und
jetzt müssen wir tatsächlich von hier
auf allen acht Seiten 21 Blöcke nach
oben gehen
von daher euch auch hier eine ganz kurze
timelapse
[Musik]
oben angekommen gehen wir jetzt auf
jeder Seite ein zwei drei vier fünf
mehr ein bisschen habe ich noch sechs
sieben acht zu jeder Seite so dass das
Wasser was genau ach Blöcke weit fließt
perfekt hier endet ohne dass es runter
geht und jetzt gehen wir hier auf jeder
Seite nach oben denn das hier werden die
Wände darstellen und das hier sind dann
so ein bisschen hier die da unten
endlich mal sparen können die werde ich
mir auch spannen ah werde ich mir die
Spannen glaube ich werde mir die auf
jeden Fall sparen denn dadurch gewinnen
wir noch mal ein bisschen mehr Koppel
Stones ich werde jetzt auch erstmal
meine Fackeln in die Hand nehmen ihr
fragt euch wahrscheinlich warum ich
genau 20 Fackeln benötige ich habe
natürlich in meiner testwelt ihr kennt
mich kleinen Mathematiker Architektur
Idioten ich habe natürlich diese blöden
Grafikfehler ne weil kommen die das
richtig auf guck mal eins zwei drei vier
fünf sechs so zack zwei brauchen wir
noch für die wasserlänge Zack und zack
und dann gehen wir hier nach oben um die
Wand darzustellen ich habe natürlich
meiner testwelt wieder geschaut wie viel
guckt euch das mal an
das ist so knuffig
unsere kleine Melonen ist auch schon
gewachsen aber gut ich habe auf jeden
Fall in meiner testwelt natürlich direkt
erstmal geschaut um das Dach
auszuleuchten damit nicht auf dem Dach
da habe ich natürlich einen Schritt
weiter gedacht als alle die
monsterfarben irgendwie auf Youtube
zeigen damit auf dem Dach nicht noch was
bauen uns irgendwie runterfällt oder
irgendwelche Enderman irgendwie am Start
sind plötzlich habe ich natürlich genau
geguckt wie viele Fackeln wir brauchen
um das Dach perfekt auszuleuchten zack
89 Bam Bam Bam hier an der Seite wieder
rüber ähm dementsprechend habe ich mir
genau 21 Fackeln gemacht hier an der
Seite die Wand ziehen und zwei drei vier
fünf sechs sieben acht neun das ist
jetzt natürlich blöd weil ich habe keine
Spitzhacke mit
besser aber nachher aus besser war jetzt
besser war verdammt wenn ich jetzt weißt
du was ich ich leuchte das einmal ganz
kurz hier alles aus und dass ich mir
einmal kurz ein neues Spitzhacke mache
da hätte ich natürlich auch voll auf die
Idee kommen können und jetzt setze ich
mal eben fixieren Wassereimer um hier
entspannt runtergehen zu können mir eine
neue Spitzhacke zu holen und
ne jetzt
weiter runter ich wusste nicht dass ich
fühle ich mich selber wie ein Monster
hier in meiner Monsterfalle ich nehme
hier vorne jetzt auch mal einen neuen
Wassereimer mit zwei Melonen sind schon
gewachsen die lassen erstmal stehen sie
sogar eigentlich ganz süß aus und werde
mir jetzt hier vorne mal eben fix eine
neue Spitzhacke machen ich denke mal
eine sollte reichen so jetzt werden wir
uns wieder nach oben bewegen sieht zwar
nicht allzu schön aus
Weg mit dir
oh mein Gott
ich habe ja total vergessen dass hier
aktuell auch was bauen kann
erstmal
hier alles ausleuchten und ich werde mir
hier vorne tatsächlich dann doch mal
eben fix die Melonen abbauen damit ich
noch mal ein bisschen was essen kann und
sich mein Hunger bald einfach noch mal
komplett auffüllt ich meine Melone
werden eh nachwachsen in der Zeit wo wir
das mit der Monsterfarm da vorne machen
Melonen werden dann eigentlich echt eine
geile nahrungsvolle sein glaube ich
dafür ist der See vielleicht sogar ganz
gut aber gut ähm euch äh mache ich eine
Tim ich mache jetzt gerade mal keine
Tablets ich werde erstmal kurz hier
hochgehen Euch zeigen wie ich jetzt
überhaupt vorgehen werde und dann werde
ich machen damit ihr wenn ihr Bock habt
das auch zu Hause nachbauen können ich
habe auch übel viele die Ems von euch
auf Instagram bekommen Instagram mit
Laserdrucker das Leute die
skyblockprojekt eins zu eins nachbauen
bei sich in Minecraft das finde ich sehr
sehr cool wie das wieder hier so ein
Projekt ist wo ihr Bock drauf habt und
wo ihr auch quasi interaktiv mit dabei
sind nicht nur über die
Kommentarfunktion hier in meinen Videos
sondern euch selber dann auch die Map
runterladen jetzt habe ich mich glaube
ich verzählt 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 nee passt
dann machen wir hier vorne noch mal eben
kurz die Wand ähm was ich machen werde
meine Damen und Herren ist jetzt einfach
nur hier vorne das hier alles ein höher
ziehen so dass die Wand so hoch ist dann
werde ich hier die Falltüren anbringen
die Truppen als falsche nicht kann ich
das auch mal eben ganz kurz zeigen und
zwar auf jeder Seite wie folgt nämlich
so einfach damit die hier nicht
hochkommen können oder keine Ahnung was
machen können und dann werde ich diese
Bereiche einmal ganz kurz ausklappen
das mal jetzt erstmal
[Musik]
so meine Damen und Herren ich bin fertig
hier oben mit der Plattform und den
truppenholz baumfalttüren dafür habe ich
nämlich diesen komischen Baum genommen
der da vorne irgendwie stand wo auch
immer noch die paar Blätter in der Luft
sind genauso wie bei der Birke da vorne
das noch ein paar Blätter müssen wir mal
gucken wenn wir dann in der Reihenfolge
die Cheat Folge machen um hier alles
abzubauen in irgendwie zwei drei Folgen
aber auch dann da hinten waren und dort
und auch bei dieser anderen komischen
kubus-insel da hinten ähm da müssen wir
mal gucken warum da vorne noch Blätter
sind ich glaube das ist einfach nur ein
Spielfehler und die werden uns so
angezeigt allerdings seht ihr auch schon
hier vorne habe ich mir eine unendliche
Wasserquelle gemacht denn ich ähm
brauche hier tatsächlich acht Mal Wasser
und habe dafür gerade als ich neue
Steine geholt habe unten auch immer mein
Wassereimer aufgefüllt ihr seht schon
was ich hier vorne gerade mache denn ich
baue jetzt eine Wand drum rum die
tatsächlich zwei Blöcke hochwertig ich
mache jetzt erstmal die erste Schiene
bzw die erste Ebene und dann gleich die
zweite Ebene damit wir einfach über die
zwei Blöcke nicht jetzt irgendwie
Enderman haben die hier spawnen sondern
wirklich vernünftige Mops also Skelette
Zombies und Creeper und vor allem auch
die Spinnen die wir benötigen für ein
Bett also tendenziell erstmal für Seide
aber danach dann für ein Bett so erste
Ebene haben wir fertig jetzt kommt die
zweite Ebene darauf bauen wir dann
gleich tatsächlich nur noch ein Dach was
wir ausleuchten werden wofür ich ja 20
Fackeln benötige und dann sind wir
eigentlich schon fertig ich habe hier
unten ja alles gerade so ein bisschen
ausleuchtet das müssen wir dann gleich
wegnehmen damit äh die Monster natürlich
spawnen weil wenn hier ein gewisser
nicht Pegel ist haben die natürlich
keinen Bock spawnen nicht Zack und ich
habe die Hoffnung und deswegen ziehe ich
auch gerade so durch dass wir das alles
noch hinkriegen bevor die Nacht einen
berichtet damit ich hier wir hier kein
blaues Wunder erleben in der Zeit wo die
Monster dann spawnen werde ich dann
nicht geschafft zack in der Zeit wo die
unten mich so ein bisschen noch um den
Weg kümmern hier vorne dass das ein
bisschen schöner wird mit fichtenzäunen
äh jetzt muss ich hier so ein bisschen
aufpassen ich weiß nicht ob das was wird
ne
ich mache euch noch mal glaube ich eine
ganz fixe timelapse während ich hier das
Dachbau weil das ist doch ein bisschen
langweilig jetzt
[Musik]
so meine Damen und Herren die Sonne ist
noch nicht untergegangen ich glaube wir
haben noch so zwei Minuten Zeit in der
wir jetzt hier vorne die Monster fahren
zum Leben erwecken können ich bin in der
Aufnahme bei ca 2 Stunden das ist die
längste Skyblock mit Luca Folge aller
Zeiten bisher von daher würde ich mich
sehr sehr doll freuen wenn ihr jetzt
schon mal einen Daumen hoch da lassen
würdet mein Kanal abonnieren würdet und
vielleicht sogar auf die Glocke klicken
würde so dass wenn ein neues Video
online geht ihr eine Benachrichtigung
bekommt und äh nicht immer mich auf
Instagram oder hier in den Youtube
Kommentar unter der letzten Folge durch
Löchern möchten
ich mich auch nicht dran und dann ähm
verwechsel ich irgendwie die Uhrzeit
oder hat dann irgendwie doch so Stress
dass ich nicht hinkriege so letzter
Wassereimer ich werde die Wasserquelle
hier vorne zu bauen denn die benötigen
wir nicht das ist alles nur unnötiger
Platz der dann verschwendet wird für
etwaige Monster hier vorne die ganzen
und ich habe tatsächlich noch ein paar
übrig also ich habe einen Stick zu viel
abgebaut allerdings habe ich jetzt eine
Stunde abbauen oder 55 Minuten ist auch
relativ egal hier vorne machen wir das
wieder zu und hier vorne auch ich checke
noch mal alles ab hier unten ist noch
irgendwo Licht an das ist aber glaube
ich weil ich meine fackelhalter warum
ist denn
hier vorne habe ich noch nicht warte mal
machen wir hier ein Cobblestone hin den
abbauen zack jetzt müsste das auch hier
genau jetzt geht's in jeder Richtung
perfekt hier vorne Spawn gleich was ich
muss jetzt schnell hier raus weil da
geht's gleich richtig los egal ob Tag
oder Nacht das wird zu jeder Uhrzeit
funktioniert werdet ihr dann auch noch
sehen heute in der Folge am Ende und
jetzt geht's darum dass wir hier oben
alles schnell ausleuchten zack 1 2 3 4
zack 1 2 3 4 5 zack 1 2 3 4 5 zack 1 2 3
4 zack 1 2 3 4 5 zack 1 2 3 4 5 zack so
das funktioniert auf jeden Fall ähm
jetzt müssen wir nur hier vorne zack
genau in diese Richtung gehen so dass
das alles in einem Kreuz ist das Problem
ist dass das Ganze äh leider
nicht so ganz gerade ist bzw man kann
nicht die gleichen Abstand machen das
hat mich total getriggert ich habe es
warte mal ich versucht mit drei Blöcken
Abstand zwischen den Fackeln ich habe es
versucht mit ähm mit zwei Blöcken
Abstand mit vier Blöcken oder mit fünf
Blockabstand es geht nicht also man muss
dieses 4-55 machen also dass das ganze
funktioniert man hätte 554 hätte man
auch machen können aber ich mache jetzt
einfach so ist auf jeden Fall perfekt
ausgleichen so dass hier nichts spawnen
sollte es muss immer ganz kurz gucken
ich glaube hier vorne war das Wasser das
werde ich jetzt wenn ich jetzt so machen
zack Wasser einmal mitnehmen und jetzt
baut sich das Wasser glaube ich von oben
ab genau das baut sich ab das heißt wir
können hier perfekt runtersleiten und
jetzt sollte die mobben endlich in Folge
10 oder so sind wir mittlerweile auch
endlich mal fertig sind noch ein paar
Items die runtergeflogen sind dass sie
bei euch mal eben fix ab oder dürfen wir
nicht runterfallen da auch nicht Zack
und zack ja
da geht es nämlich schon los
heute ist es 18 Uhr
das Video soll genau jetzt online gehen
es tut mir leid das ist jetzt zu spät
online gegangen ist aber wenn wir jetzt
schon über länger haben dann machen wir
es jetzt auch
tschüss Wasser wenn wir über länger
haben machen was jetzt auch richtig ihr
könnt ja erstmal schön spawnen wir bauen
jetzt erstmal den Weg hier noch ein
bisschen schöner und dafür habe ich
selbstverständlich gerade schon hier
Steine reingepackt hier vorne nicht
allerdings benötigen wir ja ein bisschen
steinzieher kommt meine Melone ist auch
neu gewachsen wundervoll zack wir
benötigen erstmal ein bisschen was zu
essen Melonenscheiben Essen die halten
halt leider nicht so doll satt wie jetzt
beispielsweise im Brot oder Fleisch aber
ihr wisst ich will eigentlich kein
Fleisch essen von Zombies oder so eine
Zeit weg kommt ich habe mich an so eine
Mutter die halt irgendwie äh damit sie
wegkommt
nicht McDonald's
also das sollte reichen und dann haben
wir noch Fichtenholz Säule kann ich noch
mal eben gucken Fichtenstämme haben wir
noch was an Fichtenholz Bretter in
drinne das Fichtenholz äh ich glaube da
vorne haben wir noch
drin wenn ich mich nicht irre ja genau
äh können wir auch das war eben ganz
kurz nutzen die fichtensteine mache ich
mal eben hierzu zack zack zack zack zack
zack zack
auf jeden Fall ein paar mehr Zäune 36
Stück ja wir machen mal alle komm machen
wir mal so haben wir 52 Steinziegel und
Fichtenholz Sonne kommen jetzt wird auch
noch Nacht Zack und jetzt können wir das
ganze hier mal eben kurz ein bisschen
schöner machen so dass wir dann hier
tatsächlich auf jeder Seite sondern
schön äh weg haben hier vorne auch da
brauchen wir tatsächlich noch ein
bisschen mehr Fichtenholz äh da vorne
ist noch neue Baum gewachsen da vorne
auch das machen wir dann alles weiter in
der nächsten Folge aber nur mit dir
erstmal so grob sieht wo es hingehen
soll einfach das hier vorne das hat mich
ein Abständen ich weiß gar nicht wir
hatten noch gar keine richtigen Abstände
dann machen wir mal eins zwei drei vier
fünf zack 1 2 3 4 5 zack 1 2 3 4 5 Zack
und eins zwei drei vier fünf zack dann
sind wir schon mal der Monster fahren
dann setzen eine drauf und dann immer
perfekt immer abwechselnd hier damit das
passt den Workbench crafting table merkt
dann werde ich mal wieder mitnehmen
brauchen wir hier vorne definitiv
erstmal nicht mehr das heißt hier kann
alle
ey das nervt doch nur noch
das nervt doch wirklich nur noch
nicht jetzt kommt auch noch
entspannt Bruder jetzt kommt er auch
noch hier vorne in meine blöde Farm rein
oder was der Idiot ein Tag später so
meine Damen und Herren ich habe jetzt
einfach mal gerade abgewartet bis sie
die Sonne wieder aufgeht ihr hört glaube
ich schon die Phantome sterben irgendwo
ich habe auch hier vorne ein bisschen
mal wieder Samen reingepackt in den
Komposter so dass wir vielleicht da oben
hat noch ein paar Partikel gesehen die
sind auf jeden Fall gerade gestorben
also dass du noch ein bisschen mehr
Knochenmehl bekommen die Melone hier ist
auch fertig meine Achse ist kaputt und
dann noch ein bisschen mehr Melonen
essen wir hatten schon so lange keine
volle Lebenszeit mehr aber gut ihr seht
schon da vorne da sind auf jeden Fall
eine Menge äh Monster am Start von daher
meine Damen und Herren der finale Moment
die monsterfahrt seit zehn Folgen
sag jetzt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wie krank
wie krank ist das bitte die krank
funktioniert dieses Ding ich laufe
einmal drumrum
und wir schauen mal ganz kurz was wir
haben wir haben insgesamt 10 Knochen 20
Pfeile 20 Schwarzpulver 16 fortetes
Fleisch und zwei Fäden
von jetzt vielleicht insgesamt 8 Minuten
warten oder so
schaffe ich das mal an
das ist brutal
ich trau mich immer nicht so richtig
hier vorne lang laufen das müssen wir
noch alles ein bisschen schöner machen
dafür brauchen wir noch mehr also
Steinziegel habe ich kann man
theoretisch schon drumherum gehen aber
ich brauche noch mehr Fichtenholz und
Zäune und alles mögliche ich würde
allerdings sagen dass du das in der
nächsten Folge machen ich habe zwei
Stunden 15 heute aufgenommen meine Damen
und Herren die Monster Farben steht das
was wert sorry dass das Video wieder zu
spät kam aber jetzt wisst ihr mal wie
das ist ich plane damit hey wenn ich
mich 13 Uhr an den PC setze kann das
Video um 18 online kommen so 5 Stunden
für ein Video okay
dass ich jetzt zwei Stunden erstmal
vorher das Ding gebaut habe
konzeptioniert habe und jetzt über zwei
schon aufgenommen habe und jetzt noch
mal zwei drei Stunden mindestens
schneiden werde das bringt niemand also
wenn es euch gefallen hat Daumen hoch
abonniert meinen Kanal klickt auf die
Glocke
wir sehen uns morgen wieder in einem
anderen Video oder auf dem zweiten Kanal
lucrew ist heute auch wieder online
gegangen ich werde euch mal hier ein
schaut euch gerne an eine reaction
darauf was Jungs bei Mädels unattraktiv
finden und ich sage meine Meinung dazu
sehr sehr cooles Video geworden
ich bin platt und ich bin auch noch
erkältet und krank gerade ey ich gehe
jetzt na ich muss schneiden jetzt haut
rein